[Musique]
les pandora paper se saigne nouveau
scandale d'évasion fiscale qui vient
d'être révélée après une enquête
journalistique
s'appuyant sur une fuite de plusieurs
millions de documents issus de sociétés
de services financiers installés dans
des paradis fiscaux des milliardaires
des célébrités mais surtout des
responsables politiques de différents
pays aurait eu ainsi recourra à ces
sociétés pour dissimuler avoirs et
transactions et échapper à des taxes on
trouve ainsi des personnalités bien
connues comme dominique strauss kahn
tony blair l'ancien premier ministre
britannique
les présidents équatorien
chypriote ukrainien et d'autres il y a
même shakira et claudia schiffer shakira
quand même le scandale est totale enfin
pas vraiment puisque finalement la
plupart de ces démarches d'évasion
fiscale je mets des guillemets qui
représenterait plusieurs milliers de
milliards de dollars seraient en fait
légal pour la plupart nous doit de faire
condamner les personnes incriminées l'aï
si hadji l'international consortium for
investigative journalist qui a sorti
l'enquète chercherait surtout à mettre
en évidence un certain décalage entre
les discours anti corruption de certains
politiques et leurs capacités parfois à
pratiquer l'évasion fiscale en france
cela pourrait permettre en tout cas à
bercy de récupérer quelques millions
avec quelques contrôles fiscaux bien
senti avec les panama peppers révélé
aussi par là ici hadji en 2016 la france
a récupéré jusqu'à présent 126 millions
d'euros avec 50 redressement sur la base
de 519 contrôles fiscaux